aka spider-man aka the spider menace
but rest assured dear viewer good night
Welcome back everyone this will be my spider-man
no way home video for the venom alternate ending
in deleted scenes with the venom character
the writers of the movie reveal that they
originally had a lot of different plans for
the venom character so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel i do marvel
videos every week there's a bunch of big
stuff coming up so be sure to subscribe to get
everything careful for spoilers from spider-man
no way home if you have not seen the movie yet
because we need to talk about the ending and
what happens with the venom character but the
writers of the movie reveal that they did in
fact start with an alternate plan for venom in
the film in the theatrical cut he just appears
as a post-credits scene like a really quick tag
scene or mid-credit scene technically to pay off
the venom look thereby carnage post-credit scene
that we already saw of him being teleported into
the mcu universe and then seeing spider-man and
hyping up a big fight between the two of them
they just have a funny scene of him getting drunk
at the bar after the events of the venomoloth
carnage post-credit scene with the football
as life character from ted lasso if you felt
like this actor was familiar but you couldn't
remember where you saw him it was from ted lasso
venom and eddie brock basically recapped the
events of the marvel movies the infinity saga
movies talking about iron man the hulk infinity
stones the infinity gauntlet the bartender yells
at him for joking about the snap and the five
year time jump because he lost his family and then
eddie brock says well maybe we should go to new
york city and talk to this spider-man character
before he and the venom symbiote get teleported
back to his universe by dr strange's second spell
at the end of the film but they do leave behind a
piece of the symbiote so that marvel and sony can
do their own version of a symbiote saga in the new
tom hall and spider-man trilogy in the mcu if you
weren't sure what's happening between marvel and
sony he is staying in the mcu issues of sharing
the character with sony so versions of spider-man
including tom hall and spider-man will sometimes
eventually show up in sony driven films although
i wouldn't be surprised if this little piece of
symbiote bonds with the bartender first and then
slowly jumps from host to host until it makes its
way into tom hall and spider-man but according
to the writers venom's storyline in the movie
was originally supposed to be way bigger if you
felt like the movie wasn't already big enough like
there was already a lot of crazy stuff happening
in the third act with toby mcguire spider-man and
andrew garfield spider-man entering the movie but
according to the writers venom was legit supposed
to be on screen fighting in that huge final
battle at the statue of liberty with tom holland
spider-man toby maguire andrew garfield spider-man
in the sinister six characters the writers didn't
reveal exactly how those scenes were going to play
out during the final battle like during the statue
of liberty fight they tried to give special
moments to all three different versions of
spider-man each of them get a lot of good scenes
a lot of good moments so it was already a lot for
them to juggle like it would have been hard to
work venom in but apparently there was a version
they started the movie with venom in this big
final fight also having his own moments and scenes
but since they ended the venom let the b carnage
post credit scene with him saying that guy like he
thought that spider-man was a bad guy they
needed to stop and eddie in the theatrical
post-credit scene said maybe i should go to new
york and talk to the spider-man guy i think it's
safe to say venom would have started the movie
the same way that dr octopus did very similar
arc like he starts out in the movie fighting
spider-man thinking that he's a villain in tom
holland spider-man thinks that venom is another
multiverse film that he needs to help like why are
you trying to kill me i'm trying to save you hi do
i know you and quickly before the big final battle
venom would realize that spider-man is a good guy
and then try to help him toby maguire and andrew
garfield during the final fight and it would have
just been an even bigger even crazier version
of the fight that we saw in the theatrical cut
the writers also confirmed my theory about how
tom hardy's venom recognized tom hall and
spider-man it's because of the hive memories
across the multiverse the writers basically said
what i've been saying since my venom look there
be carnage post credit scene video so i'll
link that video below in the description as
well along with the other videos but the idea
is that the symbiotes all have this multiverse
hive mind linking them across the multiverse in
genetic memory that allows each symbiote to access
the memories of all the other symbiotes in every
universe going back to the creation of their rays
80 billion light years of hive knowledge across
universes would explode your tiny little brain so
the spider-man no way home writers confirmed that
in the venom let the b carnage post credit scene
when venom says that guy what the marvel and sony
people meant is that he's seeing spider-man in the
costume and the symbol and making the connection
to toby maguire spider-man from spider-man 3
by accessing the memories of the topher grace
venom symbiote but it's not perfect recall so
he just sort of mixing and matching things in his
head like things are all bleeding together so he
remembers a version of spider-man that looks kind
of like this but not exactly like this so he says
oh that guy he looks kind of like that guy
thinking of toby maguire spider-man so it's
not a topher grace venom cameo scene or anything
like that for people that wondered why he wasn't
referenced anywhere in the movie but it's about as
close as you could get to referencing his version
of the character and yes they did tease alternate
spider-man no way home post-credit scenes
featuring toby mcguire and andrew garfield's
versions of spider-man like they discussed
having legit post-credit scenes for both of their
characters in the theatrical cut doctor strange's
second spell just sends them home when all the
other sinister six characters get sent home and
that's the last time you see them but the writers
said when they were developing toby and andrew's
story lines there were a lot of conversations
about teasing the future of their characters in
the larger multiverse like what was going to be
happening to them next after the events of this
film and as a lot of you have suspected the marvel
and sony people had talked about the possibility
of bringing them back for more cameos in future
movies you probably saw a lot of this in your
timeline the past couple of weeks since the movie
came out like marvel and sony want tobey mcguire
and andrew garfield back for more movies they said
that one of toby mcguire's big things when he was
signing on to the film was that he didn't want
the writers to completely script out everything
that happened to his spider-man after the end
of spider-man 3 like he wanted as light a touch
as possible like very loose references at best
that's why in the movie you only briefly hear
him mention having a family with his version of mj
and present-day and kind of alluding to what might
have happened to his character like he gave andrew
garfield spider-man a pep talk saying it's totally
possible for you to have a family like when he
was giving andrew garfield spider-man that pep
talk saying it's totally possible for him to have
a family and be spider-man because andrew garfield
spider-man just had not moved on from his versions
of gwen stacy like he hadn't fallen in love with
anyone else after that but andrew garfield on the
other side of that when he was signing on to the
movie the writer said that he loved all the ideas
that they pitched to him about what happened to
his character after the end of amazing spider-man
2. about how he went super dark after gwen stacy's
death turned rage full bitter stop pulling his
punches for those of you who have been seeing all
the amazing spider-man 3 posts in your timeline
so that's why they wrote so much more story about
what happened to him after amazing spider-man 2
than they did for say like tobey maguire after
the end of spider-man 3 because toby specifically
asked them not to do that and andrew garfield was
like oh hell yes please do that i think a lot
of that was because andrew garfield did not
get that third spider-man film and toby maguire
did like there was so much more story to tell
for andrew garfield spider-man than there was
for tobey maguire's so bringing it back around
to amazing spider-man 3 they basically implied in
the film through andrew's story that he either had
or was getting ready to have a version of his own
symbiote saga like his version of a tobey maguire
venom storyline in spider-man 3. because the whole
idea in spider-man 3 is that he goes super dark
rageful and bitter and that's when he gets the
symbiote and it just makes him that much worse
you'll get your rent when you fix this damn
door there've also recently been rumors that
venom three will be a multiverse movie with tom
hardy's venom encountering a version of spider-man
and that could always wind up being andrew
garfield spider-man that's just a rumor though i
think andrew garfield for sure will show up again
in another multiverse or spider-verse spider-man
movie toby maguire 2 eventually but probably not
as much as andrew garfield andrew garfield stole
every scene he was in during spider-man no way
home like they legit redeemed his character
and his amazing spider-man movies a lot electro
probably got the biggest glow up metaphorically
and literally of any of the sinister six villains
in bringing this back around to the spider-verse
movies i've mentioned this before but the animated
spider-man across the spider-verse producers
have also implied that tom holland will cross
over in one of the spider-verse sequel movies
the next one across the spider-verse is actually a
two-parter so at least by part two and originally
in the very first spider-man into the spider-verse
movie they had wanted to do toby mcguire and
andrew garfield cameos but at the time like
around 2017-2018 when they would have actually
been recording their cameos sony apparently
said that it was too soon to bring them back
now remember this is a couple years ago but
clearly now in present day is the right time
since spider-man no way home is basically a
live-action spider-verse movie and with the big
miles morales easter egg during spider-man no way
home just talking about miles morales in the mcu
there are a number of different ways they can
introduce him but the boss level spider-man move
they should go for is just having the animated
miles morales travel into the live-action mcu
earth at the very end of the spider-man across the
spider-verse part 2 movie like they end that movie
with a post-credit scene of him traveling from
an animated universe into the live-action mcu
if you're an old-school simpsons fan they
actually did this twist during a treehouse
of horror episode homer simpson gets teleported
from an animated universe into the real world
and you see his avatar walking around a regular
street all freaked out like what is happening
they also did a version of this on gravity falls
with the animated actor so like it flashes from
the animated characters to their voice over actors
you also notice linda cardellini is here she plays
hawkeye's wife in the mcu she was a character on
gravity falls so that's why she's sitting here
when they flash to the live-action version of
the characters but they should just do a miles
morales version of this looking kind of like the
gravity falls version where the animated character
just jumps into live action and is played by
a live action actor and even though all this
venom stuff is really cool there's still a bunch
of other deleted scenes that i need to do a video
about they've revealed a whole bunch of things
that they just cut out of the film so i might
do that video in the next couple of days as well
congratulations superman theaterizer 42 you're the
giveaway winner from my last big spider-man video
please email me on the about page of my channel
so i can get your contact details everyone click
here to learn about a bunch more spider-man no
way home deleted scenes in alternate endings and
click here for my full doctor strange multiverse
of madness trailer video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and happy new year!